marine ce n'est pas jean-marie mais ce
n'est pas non plus la marine d'il ya
cinq ans en tout cas ce ne sont plus
exactement les mêmes propositions alors
la candidate et rennes ne s'est pas
transformé en bolchévique antispécistes
mais certaines de ses positions ou tout
de même évolué et notamment sur l'europe
rappelez vous fin en 2017 en toute
première place des 144 engagements
présidentiels 2 marine le pen on
trouvait ceci retrouver notre liberté la
maîtrise de notre destin en restituant
au peuple français sa souveraineté pour
cela une négociation sera engagée avec
nos partenaires européens suivi d'un
référendum sur notre appartenance à
l'union européenne désormais plus de
fric site mais plutôt une modification
de la hiérarchie des normes françaises
j'inscris la supériorité du droit
constitutionnel sur le droit européen
je fait voter par les français une
modification constitutionnelle
indiquant que tous les textes européens
qui sont contraires à notre loi suprême
c'est à dire notre constitution non pas
d'application dans le droit interne
français plus de sortie de l'europe et
donc pas d'abandon de l'euro non plus
mais une réforme de l'intérieur des
institutions et de la monnaie de l'union
autre renoncement la suppression de la
double nationalité
extra-européenne c'était une mesure du
programme de marine le pen en 2017
contraindre les français également
citoyen d'un autre pays extra-européens
à choisir l'une des deux nationalités il
n'en est plus question aujourd'hui j'ai
rencontré des milliers de gens par
exemple des marocains qui juridiquement
ne peuvent renoncer à leur nationalité
car leur pays l'interdît honnêtement je
préfère mettre ça de côté car c'est
comme mettre du sel sur des plaies
ouvertes marine le pen conserve
toutefois comme il ya cinq ans la
suppression du droit du sol côté
sociétal là aussi quelques changements
la candidate frontiste d'il ya cinq ans
souhaitait notamment abroger la loi
taubira sur le mariage pour tous est
instauré à la place un pacs améliorée
aujourd'hui cette proposition n'est plus
à l'ordre du jour en tout cas pas à
l'ordre du jour des premières années de
son hypothétique mandat je mettrai en
place une forme de moratoire pendant
trois ans sur tous les sujets sociétaux
parce que je pense que la société
française n'a pas besoin de fracturation
supplémentaires dans le même temps je
veux mettre en place un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
ceux qui souhaitent revenir sur des lois
il réunit cinq cent mille signatures et
il y aura un référendum organisé sur ces
sujets pour que la société réponde aux
sujets de société on peut enfin noter un
durcissement vis-à-vis de l'éolien que
marine le pen souhaitent démanteler tout
comme elle compte cesser de
subventionner le solaire bref il y a
donc eu des évolutions entre les
programmes de 2017 et 2022 et d'autres
pourraient encore survenir alors
certains d'entre vous peuvent se dire
qu'il s'agit là de changements à la
marge et bien détrompez-vous nombre des
sujets que je viens de lister sont des
marqueurs puissant au sein de
l'électorat nationaliste il n'est pas
impossible qu'ils aient participé à
pousser certains des proches de la
candidate du rassemblement national à
rejoindre son rival éric zemmour un
paradoxe après tant d'années passées par
la fille de jean marie le pen à se
dédiaboliser devenu plus fréquentable
marine le pen en perd ses fréquentations